I think both parents had a role in my
life my mother as a as a assimilated
American much more than my father who
was a tailor and while a great craftsman
to this day I wear a lot of the suits
that he made for me decades and decades
ago and I have cousins Italian cousins
and French cousins there is a mixture of
French and Italian in my background
because my first cousin when my father
saw I went to France in 1911 years
before World War one and so I have a lot
of tailoring connections my relatives so
my my father impressed upon me a pride
and craft and so in a cry a pride in
crafting a sentence is what I am now
connecting to my father's pride in craft
in his way he sewed the way he shaped
the garment the way he he made something
that lasted clothes made by him or the
other people that I mentioned who are
related who are tailors for four or five
generations beginning in Italy are
people who take identify with their work
and and take pride in the fact that
their work sometimes lives beyond them
and I feel that way as a writer may
sound arrogant of me but I'm not really
arrogant about it but I'm very prideful
and caring about what I do and I get
this from my father
well when I was young and I was not
fully formed so I wasn't wearing the
clothes that I would wear when I was in
my 20s when I came to New York I came to
New York to stay in 1956 my history is
as you know I was born in the 30s and I
went to college in 1949 in 1953 and then
I went in the Army for a couple years
and in 1955 out of the army I came to
New York and from that so it's been more
than a half a century that I've lived in
the city and I became aware of the of
the contemporary mode of fashioned but
even as a reporter I had my own sense of
fashion I was on the New York Times Tom
Wolfe was on the New York Herald Tribune
at the same time and and he certainly
had a sense of fashion and we are that
were the two people who were in daily
journalism contemporaries in New York in
the mid-50s and stayed in journalism
until the mid-60s when both of us went
on to write magazine pieces and then
later on books
we always had a sense of wanting to as I
put it dress up for the story I mean
what i mean by that is is I thought what
I was doing was very important when I
was a daily journalist so that's really
important I thought it was really
important because I believe that the
people who work with me as colleagues on
the New York Times were least likely to
lie than anybody else to New York
I thought the politicians were
definitely liars I believe most business
people were liars I had a real cynical
sense of the integrity of people and I
had a real lofty sense of what we
journalists in the New York Times
building were later on I was a court of
course dismayed by some of the lying
journalists that came to forbear upon
the papers reputation such as Jayson
Blair some years ago people's other
people you might have heard about on
other newspapers as well but by and
large I believe that being a journalist
was a very honorable profession because
the American public was less likely to
be lied to by our group than by public
officials or businesspeople
or lawyers oh god the lawyers leave us
away from that subject
you